el avión en el que viajaba la escena
valley tuvo que hacer una parada de
emergencia ya que su estado empeoró
luego de haber tomado una taza de té en
el aeropuerto de la ciudad de tomsk a
las afueras de la clínica donde fue
hospitalizado su médico confirmó la
sospecha de un envenenamiento
alexei está en estado grave pero estable
se trata de una intoxicación con un
agente desconocido encefalopatía tóxica
está en coma
pero cómo
noval y es un feroz crítico del
presidente ruso vladimir putin en junio
describió la votación sobre la reforma
constitucional de rusia como un golpe de
estado pues permitirá al mandatario
quedarse en el poder otros dos mandatos
más la portavoz del opositor informó que
noval y será trasladado lo más pronto
posible la familia y los médicos de
alexéi navalni tomaron la decisión de
trasladarlo a otra clínica al menos
había que hacerlo porque en homs que en
el hospital donde se encuentra ahora
mismo no hay equipo suficiente para
realizar todas las pruebas y
procedimientos necesarios además debe
hacerse por cuestiones de seguridad
por su parte el portavoz del gobierno
ruso dijo que no se opondrán sin aval y
tiene que seguir un tratamiento en el
extranjero
a pesar de que las fronteras están
cerradas muchos de nuestros ciudadanos
viajan al extranjero para recibir
tratamiento por supuesto estaríamos
listos para investigar urgentemente esas
solicitudes si las hubiera
varias personas protestaron en san
petesburgo tras el presunto
envenenamiento del líder de la oposición
esta no sería la primera vez que una
sustancia no sirve es utilizada contra
opositores políticos a la lista de
envenenamiento se suma el de peor ver si
los activista y miembro del grupo puse y
riot y el del ex agente ruso serguéi
skripal y su hija giulia